Now comes the moment of truth.
I have been waiting for this moment for quite a while to let you experience first hand
how to visualize data, and in this unit, you will do everything entirely by yourself.
I will give you data and you will plot those data and answer simple questions.
But there is one thing to know--this unit is strictly optional.
The reason is there is programming involved in this unit and programming was not a prerequisite.
However, I will make sure what you have to do is extremely simple, is very well explained,
and a whole lot of fun, so if you choose to take this unit, you will visualize some interesting data
using a very simple programming tool. This over here is the Udacity programming interface.
Don't freak out--all I'll do is give instructions over here, and I'll hit the run button.
As I scroll down, you can see a histogram of the data.
So this has been computed automatically now.
There are five data categories from 2.0 to 6.0, and you can see the frequency of data ions
in the vertical dimension--1, 4, 3, 1, and 1 again.
Now this is a familiar histogram. Just look out how easy it was to generate this.